Nos piden simplificar "d" que multiplica a
"4d" elevado a la potencia 1/2.
Veamos que podemos hacer aquí.
Hay muchos caminos para hacer esto,
aquí revisaremos todos.
"d" por "4d"  a la 1/2....
"4d" a la 1/2, enfoquémonos en esto...
"4d" a la 1/2, si tomas el producto de 2 factores
y lo elevas a un exponente,
es lo mismo que elevar cada uno de los
factores al exponente y después realizar el producto.
Así es que, "4d" a la 1/2, lo puedes escribir como
4 elevado a la 1/2, por "d" elevado a la 1/2
y por supuesto, eso multiplicado por "d".
Podría poner un paréntesis aquí pero, no importa
porque estoy tomando el producto de estos 3 términos.
Así es que ponemos esa "d" adelante
y aquí tenemos 2 maneras de hacer esto.
Elevamos 4 a la potencia 1/2,
con lo cual sacamos su raíz cuadrada principal,
es decir, su raíz cuadrada positiva.
Así es que esto va a ser
4 elevado a la potencia 1/2 es igual a 2,
podemos poner ahora
esta "d",
después del 2...
vamos a ponerla después del 2
y esto multiplicado por "d" elevado a la potencia 1/2
y aquí hay varias maneras de representar esto.
dependiendo de...
yo no sé, cómo lo veas, digamos, más estético,
podrías considerar que esto es "d" elevado
a la potencia 1 y este es "d" la potencia 1/2,
por lo cual esto sería entonces 2 por "d" elevado
a la 1 más 1/2 que es 1 entero 1/2
ó "d" elevado a la 3/2.
Así es que este es una simplificación de la expresión.
Otra simplificación es considerar que "d" elevado a 1/2 es la raíz cuadrada de 1/2,
así es que esto también podría escribirse como
2 por "d" por la raíz cuadrada de "d".
Cualquiera de estas 2 son simplificaciones válidas,
lo que es interesante aquí, es considerar que ambas, representan lo mismo.